foreign
on the 26th of February Italy witnessed
one of the worst migrant boat crashes in
decades
um
at least 94 people died around 35 are
believed to be children
foreign
Sky News working with Media Partners
across Europe and Lighthouse reports has
spent more than two months investigating
[Music]
the journey started in cesme in Turkey
on the 22nd of February when around 180
people boarded The Smuggler's boat
heading to Calabria in Italy hours into
the trip they broke down and transferred
onto the summer love vessel
Mediterranean is one of the most
dangerous migrant routes in the world
more than a thousand people have already
died this year attempting to get to
Europe
32 year old Zarin paid 8 000 Euros to
cross after fleeing violence in
Afghanistan he was hoping for a new life
um
this 3D reconstruction shows you how
overcrowded the boat was almost 200
people packed inside
while the Smugglers stayed up top the
families were crammed Below in little
rooms for most of the journey
they say there were no life jackets much
of the time they were locked in to avoid
detection
the weather was good here are small
group celebrates believing they've
reached Italian Waters
they have no idea they're heading
towards the storm a storm and a fatal
crash
more than five hours before the crash
some alive is spotted by a frontex
border patrol plane Eagle One at 10 26
Italian time the heat-seeking cameras
show one person on Deck but pick up a
significant thermal response noting more
people could be below
they alert the Italian authorities to
the ship as a suspected migrant vessel
and note no life jackets are visible
strong winds have already disrupted
their flight but despite this they do
not class the boat as in distress
in the hours that follow the weather
worsens Italian authorities send out two
boats to intercept the summer love but
both turn around due to the storm
no rescue operation is launched
this doesn't happen until the first
distress call is received at around 4am
by which time the summer love is sinking
and dozens of people are drowning
foreign
was on board with his uncle and
six-year-old brother Sultan they'd fled
Syria hoping to meet family in Germany a
new life Sultan would never live to see
um
Sultan froze to death in his brother's
arms his uncle shows us his little grave
after the boat sank Rescuers scoured the
sand for survivors the desperate
who'd managed to make it to shore
but the body bags kept on lining up
an eight-month-old baby and 70 year old
pensioner believed to be among the Dead
who do you blame for what happened that
night
uh
foreign
we contacted the Italian Coast Guard and
Guardia de finanza to ask why a rescue
wasn't launched sooner they said they
couldn't comment due to an ongoing
investigation into the crash
denied any wrongdoing saying when they
filmed the boat it wasn't in distress
and that all of their findings went to
the Italian authorities who have the
power to launch a search and rescue
but many who made this Crossing hoping
for new lives believe they were
forgotten